Et si je pouvais vous raconter une histoire
dont vous vous souviendriez avec tout votre corps
et pas juste avec votre esprit ?
Tout au long de ma vie de journaliste j'ai vraiment essayé
d'écrire des histoires qui feraient une différence
et éveilleraient l'intérêt des lecteurs.
J'ai travaillé au tirage, dans le documentaire,
et dans la diffusion.
Mais ce n'est qu'en me tournant vers la réalité virtuelle
que j'ai commencé à observer
des réactions intenses et authentiques du public
qui m'ont époustouflée.
Ce qui est formidable avec la réalité virtuelle, RV,
c'est que je peux vous mettre en situation
au beau milieu de l'histoire.
Quand vous mettez ces lunettes, elles suivent le mouvement de vos yeux ;
vous ressentez dans tout votre corps
l'impression d'y être vraiment.
Il y a cinq ans, j'ai vraiment commencé à insister
pour qu'on utilise la réalité virtuelle en accord avec le journalisme.
Et je voulais faire un article sur la famine.
Il y a des familles américaines affamées, des banques alimentaires débordées
et souvent à court de nourriture.
Bon, je savais que je ne pouvais pas faire ressentir la faim au public,
mais je pouvais peut-être réussir à leur faire ressentir quelque chose de physique.
Donc — toujours il y a cinq ans —
mêler le journalisme et la réalité virtuelle
était considéré comme une idée plus que boiteuse,
et je n'avais pas de financements.
Croyez-moi, mes collègues se sont bien moqués de moi.
Cependant, j'avais une super stagiaire,
nommée Michaela Kobsa-Mark.
On est allé dans des banques alimentaires
et avons pris des photos et des enregistrements.
Puis un jour elle est revenue à mon bureau
et elle criait, elle pleurait.
Elle s'était tenue au milieu d'une longue queue ;
la réceptionniste était complètement débordée
et Michaela criait : « Ils sont trop nombreux !
Ils sont trop nombreux. »
Et un homme atteint de diabète n'a pas pu manger à temps,
son taux de sucre a chuté brusquement et il est tombé dans le coma.
Dès que j'ai entendu l'enregistrement,
j'ai su qu'il serait évocateur
de ce qui se passait réellement dans les banques alimentaires.
Donc voici la file d'attente. Regardez comme elle était longue.
Encore une fois : nous n'avions pas de financements,
donc j'ai dû reproduire la situation avec des humains virtuels,
et les gens ont demandé, supplié que l'on m'aide à créer des modèles
pour les rendre aussi précis que possible.
Puis on a essayé de transmettre ce qui s'était déroulé ce jour-là
avec autant de précision que possible.
Voix : Ils sont trop nombreux ! Ils sont trop nombreux !
Voix : Il est en train de faire une attaque.
Voix : Appelez une ambulance !
N. de la Peña : Donc l'homme à droite,
il croit qu'il tourne autour du corps.
Il croit qu'il est dans la même pièce que ce corps.
Comme s'il était à ses pieds.
Et pourtant, du coin des yeux,
il voit bien qu'il est dans un laboratoire.
Il devrait savoir qu'il n'est pas vraiment dans la rue,
mais il a l'impression d'être avec ces gens.
Il fait attention à ne pas marcher sur le malade
qui n'est en fait pas vraiment là.
Donc cet article a fini par arriver au Sundance de 2012.
Un exploit puisque c'était le premier film documentaire virtuel
à y être présenté.
Quand ça a été à nous, j'étais vraiment terrifiée.
Je ne savais pas comment le public réagirait
et ce qui allait se passer.
On a débarqué avec ces lunettes couvertes de scotch.
Oh, tu pleures. Gina, tu pleures.
On entend la surprise dans ma voix, non ?
Et on a fini par observer cette même réaction
encore et encore :
des gens à genoux pour essayer de venir en aide au malade,
pour lui parler à l'oreille
ou pour aider de leur mieux, même s'ils n'y pouvaient rien.
Beaucoup de gens, après cette expérience, m'ont dit :
« C'était terriblement frustrant, je ne pouvais rien faire »,
et ils retiendront ce sentiment toute leur vie.
Donc après cette œuvre,
le doyen de l'école de cinéma USC, University of South California,
a fait vivre l'expérience « Hunger » au directeur du Forum Économique Mondial.
Celui-ci a retiré les lunettes,
et a immédiatement ordonné une enquête sur la Syrie.
Je voulais faire quelque chose pour les jeunes réfugiés syriens,
car les enfants ont été les plus affectés par la guerre civile en Syrie.
J'ai envoyé une équipe dans les camps de réfugiés à la frontière syrienne,
à en endroit où je n'enverrai plus une équipe aujourd'hui,
puisque c'est là que Daech opère.
Nous avons aussi récréé une scène de rue.
Une jeune fille chantonne et tout d'un coup une bombe explose.
Quand vous vous trouvez au beau milieu de la scène,
que vous entendez ces bruits,
et que vous voyez les blessés autour de vous,
ça provoque des sensations très angoissantes et réalistes.
Des victimes de vrais bombardements m'ont dit
qu'ils avaient ressenti le même genre de peur.
[La guerre civile en Syrie paraît peut-être éloignée]
[jusqu'à ce qu'on en fasse soi-même l'expérience]
(Une fille chante)
(Explosion)
[Projet Syrie]
[Une véritable expérience virtuelle]
NP : On a été invité à présenter notre œuvre
au Victoria and Albert Museum à Londres.
Et sans publicité.
On nous a mis dans la salle des tapisseries.
Nous n'avons pas été annoncés.
Donc tous ceux qui visitaient le musée par hasard
pouvaient apercevoir nos gros spots.
Peut-être qu'ils voulaient découvrir l'histoire des tapisseries.
Et ils se retrouvaient en face de nos caméras.
Mais beaucoup de gens l'ont essayé, et au bout de cinq jours,
nous avions récolté 54 pages de commentaires sur notre livre d'or.
Les conservateurs nous ont dit
qu'ils n'avaient jamais vu une telle effusion de sentiments.
« C'est tellement réaliste. » « Absolument convaincant. »
Ou encore, celui qui m'a le plus réjouie :
« On avait l'impression d'être au beau milieu d'un évènement
qu'on voit d'habitude aux informations. »
Donc ça marche, non ? Ça fonctionne.
Et peu importe vos origines, votre âge...
C'est très évocateur.
Comprenez bien, je ne dis pas que quand vous êtes dans une telle œuvre,
vous oubliez que vous êtes ici.
Mais on peut avoir l'impression d'être à deux endroits en même temps.
On peut ressentir ce que j'appelle cette ubiquité
et je crois que c'est pour ça qu'on peut ressentir une telle empathie.
Non ?
Bien sûr, ça veut dire
que je dois être très prudente en créant ces œuvres.
Et je dois obéir aux meilleures pratiques journalistiques
pour m'assurer que ces histoires percutantes
soient racontées avec intégrité.
Si nous n'enregistrons pas nous-mêmes les images,
nous devons faire très attention
à leur provenance, à leur origine,
et à leur authenticité.
Voilà un exemple :
l'histoire d'un garçon, un enfant, Trayvon Martin.
Alors âgé de 17 ans, il a acheté un soda et une sucrerie dans une boutique
et sur le chemin du retour, il a été suivi par un veilleur du quartier
au nom de George Zimmerman, qui lui a tiré dessus et l'a tué.
Pour réaliser cette expérience,
nous avons rassemblé les plans de tout le lotissement,
et reconstruit toute la scène, à l'aide de ces dessins.
Toute l'action
s'appuie sur les appels au 911 effectivement enregistrés par la police.
Nous avons déniché des informations exclusives.
Primeau Productions, le département de criminalistique
qui a reconstitué les enregistrements
a dit qu'il était prêt à témoigner
que George Zimmerman, en sortant de sa voiture,
avait armé son pistolet avant de poursuivre Martin.
Donc les principes fondamentaux du journalisme
sont respectés ici, non ?
Nous nous appuyons sur les mêmes principes qu'auparavant.
La différence est la sensation d'être en situation,
qu'on soit témoin de l'effondrement d'un homme affamé
ou qu'on croit être victime de l'explosion d'une bombe.
Voilà ce qui m'a motivée à réaliser ces œuvres,
et ce qui a guidé ma réflexion.
On essaie de rendre ça plus accessible, sans le casque, évidemment.
Nous créons des œuvres animées comme celle de Trayvon Martin.
Et ces œuvres ont eu un impact.
Certains Américains m'ont confié qu'ils avaient fait des dons,
directement depuis leur compte en banque, pour les enfants syriens réfugiés.
Et « La faim à Los Angeles » a été le point de départ
d'une nouvelle forme de journalisme,
qui, je pense, rejoindra bientôt
les autres plateformes traditionnelles.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)